ya que tenemos nuestra colección de
componentes nuestras pilas y resistor es
favoritos
podemos ensamblar los para formar
circuitos y bueno aquí tenemos uno de
esos circuitos
esta es una pila y aquí tenemos tres
resistor es pero en esta configuración a
la que le llamamos en serie lo que hay
aquí tenemos tres resistor es en serie
es una configuración muy común en el
cual estamos conectando la salida de un
resistor con la entrada del siguiente y
nuevamente la salida del resistor con la
entrada del siguiente resistor así es
que estos tres resistor es se encuentran
en una configuración en serie porque
tenemos aquí una sucesión del nodo
resistor nodo resistor nodo resistor uno
tras otro
este es el patrón que nos dice que esta
es una configuración de resistor es en
serie a este resistor le vamos a llamar
el resistor r1 este va a ser el resistor
r2
este el r3 estas letras también
representan el cuerpo y siente de
resistividad de estos resistor es y aquí
al voltaje de esta pila simplemente le
vamos a llamar be y así como están las
cosas la única incógnita es la corriente
que hay digamos que ahorita conocemos
cuánto vale ve y r1 r2 r3 y lo que
queremos es saber cuánto vale y así es
que queremos saber cuánto vale la
corriente ahora lo que sí sabemos es que
la corriente fluye y entra al resistor 1
toda la corriente está del otro lado del
resistor r 1 porque tiene que hacerlo no
se puede acumular aquí en el resistor
luego la corriente entra al resistor 2 y
sale del otro lado y vuelve a salir del
resistor r 3 y la corriente
regresa al lugar de donde salió o sea a
esta pila bueno pero ahora sí tenemos
resistor es en serie tienen que estar
conectados uno con otro entrada con
salida o entrada con salida entrada con
salida y esto lo que provoca es que
tengan la misma corriente los resistor
es en serie tienen la misma corriente y
en realidad esta es la clave lo único
que no sabemos acerca de estos resistor
es es el voltaje en cada uno de ellos a
este le vamos a llamar voltaje uno este
va a ser el voltaje 2 y este el voltaje
3 y tienen aquí su carga positiva y aquí
la negativa ahora en general si la
resistencia en cada uno de estos
resistor es es diferente si los
coeficientes de resistividad son
distintos
entonces estos voltajes tienen que ser
distintos también esta es una de las
cosas que nos dice la ley de ohm
y lo que yo quiero que nos preguntemos
en este momento del vídeo es si hay
alguna forma de sustituir a estos tres
resistor es por algún otro resistor que
provoque que haya la misma corriente esa
es la pregunta que vamos a resolver en
este vídeo pero vamos a empezar por
recordar cuál es la ley de ohm la ley de
ohm nos dice que b es igual a i por rm
aquí lo que nos está diciendo es que
para cualquier resistor el voltaje es
proporcional a la corriente ahora otra
cosa muy importante acerca de este
circuito por cómo están acomodados estos
componentes es que la suma de estos tres
voltajes que son los voltajes a lo largo
de estos tres resistor es la suma de
estos tres voltajes tiene que ser igual
a éste tenemos que ver es igual a la
suma de b1 b2
b3 justo porque estas resistencias están
acomodadas en serie pero bueno ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es escribir la ley de
ohm para cada uno de estos resistor es b
1 es igual a i y la y que es la
corriente es la misma para todos los
resistor es pero b 1 es igual a y por
ere 1 b 2 que es el voltaje en este
resistor es igual a y por ere 2 ib3 es
igual a y por r 3 y bueno nos podemos
imaginar que si aquí hubiera más
resistor es hubiera 6 resistor es
entonces aquí tendríamos 6 ecuaciones y
vueltas a estas para cada uno de esos
resistor es y aquí tendríamos también
que sumar todos esos voltajes pero lo
que haríamos sería exactamente lo mismo
y lo que vamos a hacer es sustituir cada
uno de estos voltajes en esta ecuación y
vamos a hacer una observación a partir
de eso si sustituimos de estos voltajes
lo que nos queda es que b
en lugar de v 1 tenemos y por ere uno
más y por r 2 y por el 2 más y por r 3 y
como es la misma exactamente la misma
corriente entonces podemos escribir que
es igual
por r1 y r2 mas r3 lo único que estamos
haciendo es factorizar la ahí y ahora lo
que queremos hacer es comparar esta
expresión con la ley de ohm que tenemos
ve el voltaje es igual a una corriente
por una resistencia así es que si
podemos encontrar una resistencia que
nos dé exactamente la misma ley de ohm y
bueno aquí vamos a dibujar ésta es la
batería tenemos aquí un circuito pero lo
que yo quiero decir es que si podemos
encontrar un resistor al cual le vamos a
llamar r serie y lo veríamos con una r s
pero este resistor serie es equivalente
a los otros tres resistor es en esta
configuración en serie y es equivalente
en el sentido de que la corriente fluye
exactamente de la misma forma que en
este otro circuito así es que en este
caso tenemos el voltaje igual a la
corriente
la resistencia serie y a final de
cuentas lo que estoy diciendo es que r
serie es igual a r1 y r2 + r3 y bueno
esto es lo que siempre hacemos con los
resistor es en serie podemos sustituir a
todos los resistor es por un solo
resistor pero cuya resistencia sea igual
a la suma de todas las resistencias de
los receptores en serie y ahora vamos a
hacer un ejemplo bastante rápido solo
para ver cómo funciona tenemos aquí un
circuito ya le puse cuál es la
resistencia de estos resistor es es 100
ohms 50 oms y 150 oms y digamos que el
voltaje de esta pila es 1.5 volts los
pies que es una sola batería por aquí y
lo que queremos saber es cuál es la
corriente entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es averiguar cuál es la
resistencia equivalente hasta estos tres
resistor es en serie y la forma más
fácil de averiguar eso es sustituir a
estos tres resiste
es por otro resistor que tiene una
resistencia r serie que como acabamos de
ver es la suma de las resistencias de
estos otros tres resistor es ok entonces
rs es igual a 100 la resistencia del
primer resistor más 50 50 más 150 150 y
eso es igual a 300 oms así es que esta
es la resistencia equivalente a estos 3
resistor es bueno y ahora sí vamos a
calcular la corriente y utilizando la
ley de ohm que nos dice que y es igual a
b entre r en este caso es r serie y
entonces esto es igual a b 1.5 1.5 / r
que es 300 y si hacemos estos cálculos
nos queda
0.0
05 counters o bueno otra forma de
escribir esto es decir que tenemos 5000
y amper si esta es la corriente iu y
ahora ya que sabemos cuál es la
corriente como es igual en todo el
circuito entonces ya podemos calcular el
voltaje en cada una de estas
resistencias que hoy vamos a calcular b
1 el cual es el voltaje a través de la
resistencia 1 y por la ley de ohm
sabemos que b1 es igual a y la corriente
por la resistencia 1 ya calculamos que
la corriente es 5000 jumpers 5000 y
hunters por 100
homs
esto es igual a 0.5 volts bueno vamos
con el voltaje de la resistencia 2 de 2
y el voltaje a través del segundo
resistor es igual a y la corriente que
es igual en todo el circuito por la
resistencia 2 lo cual es igual otra vez
a 5000 jumpers 5.000 amperes por 50 1150
oms lo cual es igual a 0.25 volts y
finalmente calculamos el voltaje en el
tercer resistor b 3 es igual a
por r 3 lo cual es igual a 5 mil amperes
por 150 homes lo cual es igual a 0.75
volts vamos un poquito para abajo por
aquí ya encontramos el voltaje y la
corriente en cada uno de los resistor es
así es que ya resolvimos este circuito
pero para estar un poco más seguros de
que hicimos las cuentas bien vamos a
sumar estos voltajes que nos tienen que
dar igual al voltaje total monkey 0 55
es 0 y llevamos 11 527 eso es 15 o sea
que ponemos 5 y llevamos 1 y 1000 es 110
que la suma de estos tres voltajes la
suma de los voltajes de estos tres
resistor es es 1.5 volts y eso está muy
bien porque es justo el voltaje que
tenemos aquí en la pila es justo el
voltaje que teníamos que obtener él
a través de todos estos receptores si es
igual al voltaje suministrado a este
circuito ahora hay otra cosa muy
importante que quiero mencionar en este
vídeo y es que si tenemos por ejemplo
otros tres resistor es configurados en
esta forma los vemos y podemos pensar
oye estos son otros tres resistor es en
serie ahora hay que tener mucho cuidado
aquí porque si hubiera por aquí algún
cable conectado hacia cualquier otro
componente o también si hay por aquí
otro cable conectado a este nodo de aquí
estos resistor es pareciera que están en
serie pero podría ser que haya corriente
fluyendo en estas ramas de aquí y si en
algún momento hay corriente fluyendo
afuera de la serie o bueno la forma
correcta de decirlo sería algo así como
que si en algún lugar hay corriente
fluyendo hacia alguna otra rama de lo
que parecía que era una rama en serie
entonces la corriente por
y la corriente que fluye a través de
este resistor no necesariamente es igual
a la corriente que fluye a través de
este otro resistor o a esta otra
corriente porque la corriente podría
estarse yendo hacia esos otros dos lados
de hecho para que estas dos corrientes
sean iguales la corriente que sale a
esta rama tiene que ser igual a cero
igual para que esta corriente sea igual
a esta la corriente que sale por aquí
tiene que ser igual a cero los pies que
hay que tener mucho cuidado porque
aunque veas a estos resistor es
alineados así si hay cables que se
conecten a estos nuevos estos resistor
es no están en serie a menos que la
corriente que fluye por estos cables sea
igual a cero si la corriente que fluye
por estos cables es igual a cero
entonces si puedes considerar a estos
resistor es como si estuvieran en una
configuración en serie bueno entonces
esto es algo con lo que hay que tener
mucho cuidado siempre que veamos unos
resistor es que
parece como que están en serie hay que
observar si no tienen algunas otras
ramas por las que pueda fluir corriente
en fin ya vimos aquí cómo funcionan los
resistor es en serie si en verdad están
en serie podemos simplemente sumar sus
resistencias y así obtenemos la
resistencia equivalente y listo